So, in order that you save a little time compared to Alice, Bob, and Carol,
our first quiz this unit is going to be what should you do when you can't find
and polynomial time algorithm for some important problem that you're working on.
Here are your options when you can't find a polynomial time algorithm
for a problem you're working on.
You can do some research on the problem.
You can try to show that your problem is NP complete.
You can give up right away.
You can discuss the problem with friends and possibly also experts
if they are available to you, and you might also think about settling for a suboptimal algorithm--
some algorithm that works but probably doesn't produce the best possible solution,
at least if the stakes aren't high.
So, which of these options do you think could be recommended in general?